ladies oh my god looking ray great yeah
otherwise no one is grading yeah yeah
Grady waiting right now oh hello man how
long you at hello your neck honey now
fifteen fifteen years man
where you from Grady something I'll go
warn Iranian sure you feel like right
now you putting on for your city yeah
doctor there's a lot of negativity
around with the term chiraq you know
most people from Chicago we don't claim
that that's the media so we like nah we
just regular blue-collar people like
Philly Baltimore Detroit Oakland hey
generally just named four of the most
murdering cities right there you don't
even really want to know that is
definitely we don't go about it named
four of the most murdering cities in the
UN was it love at first sight when you
first got on stage oh no no rather de la
y'all was wait why why not everyone well
I mean because you know you you can be
funny around your friends your family
but they all lie is okay and I'll tell
you what you wanna hear I don't know
none of these people here except for the
six dudes in here
right they laugh that's when you know
you can you know I mean so it took me a
while you know I kept going back at
bombing bombing bombing Wow stay
persistent to it never doubted well I
can fight so that so you got a lot of
build me I'm the way for you know you
did that that's great yeah but it was
just you know I wasn't afraid to lose
okay and I mean so if you're gonna be
big that's what a big that's actually a
very powerful statement man because I
think a stand-up comedy you have to have
that mindset a lot of people step on
that stage and you know are afraid to
fail or afraid to not hit or glass
because they not it's not personal
they don't know me yeah but I got the
power okay but my voice is a man's voice
so when I speak another shot at me I
think up some nothing
that's another Oh jail just a dream I
would definitely say greenie does have
probably one of the best voices in
comedy alpha male baby you got to be
alpha male view yeah you know when you
keep saying it I feel like you're saying
there's not that I'm supposed to be as a
mirror
hey y'all make some noise for my guy
Grady it's time to welcome to the next
level baby
[Applause]
[Music]